بعد ثمانيه اشهر من المواجهات الدمويه في
ضخمه لم يحسم اي طرف المعركه معركه بخمو
تذكر بان حرب اوكرانيا تحولت الى حرب
استنزاف امام هذا الوضع ومع اقناع الروس
والاوكرانيين تدريجيا ان الحسم العسكريه
بعيد المنال وباهض الثمن تتحرك الوساطه في
السر والعلن للبحث عن مخرج دبلوماسي
الرئاسه التركيه قالت ان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اكد لبوتين في محادثه هاتفيه انه
يولي اهميه لانهاء نزاعات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا من خلال المفاوضات في اقرب وقت
ممكن واضاف البيان اردوغان شكر بوتين على
موقفه الايجابي تجاه تمديد مبادره حبوب
البحر الاسود واذا كانت قنوات الاتصال بين
تركيا وطرفي النزاع مفتوحه رغم عدم تقديم
مبادره وساطه واضحه المعالم الصين قدمت
هذه المبادره لكن قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه
حتى الان مع طرف واحد هو روسيا الرايس
الاوكراني قال انه لم يتلقى اي عرض من
الوساطه والحوار او للقاء الزعيم الصيني
واكد انه بعث برسائل مباشره عبر القنوات
الدبلوماسيه تفيد برغبته في التحدث مع
الرئيس الصيني واعرب زينسكي عن شكوكه في
خطه السلام الصينيه قائلا ان احترام
السياده والسلامه الاقليميه يجب ان ياتي
اولا اذا الرئيس الاوكراني منفتح على
المبادره الصينيه وان بتحفظ ويبدو ان هناك
تشجيعا اوروبيا لهذا التوجه اذ قال
المستشار الالماني انه يتوقع ان تجري
الصين محادثات مع اوكرانيا واضاف انه لا
ينبغي التحدث مع الرئيس الروسي فحسب بل مع
الرئيس الاوكراني ايضا لكن الامريكيين
يشككون في قدره الصين على الوساطه الخميس
الماضي قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي
ان واشنطن لا ترى الصين وسيطا محايدا بين
كييف وموسكو واضاف ان الصين لم تدن حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا
كان كيربي يعلق على زياره الرئيس الصيني
الاخيره لموسكو التي اظهرت مستوى التقارب
الذي وصلته علاقات الصين وروسيا ترى
واشنطن ان الصين منحازه لروسيا وان
مبادرتها غير قابله للتطبيق اهم ما تضمنته
هذه المبادره الابتعاد عن عقليه الحرب
البارده ما يعني في الخطاب الصيني انهاء
هيمنه امريكا وتدخلها في شؤون الدول كما
تؤكد المبادره احترام استقلال الدول
وسيادتها ووحدتها الترابيه وهنا تصطدم
المبادره الصينيه برغبه روسيا في ضم اراضي
تعتبر وفق القانون الدولي جزءا مما يشكل
الوحده الترابيه لاوكرانيا